hi guys today we're gonna do a
spoiler-free examination of overall in
two minutes but before we begin massive
shout out to the voice actor for Mariota
Garza who shared the last video I did on
Twitter and basically just blew up my
mentions so Thank You Rico that was
honestly so cool and if you're
interested the video he shared was myrio
explained in one minute but without
further ado let's get into overall
explained in two minutes
overalls legal name is Chi Chi sake but
it's a name that he is seemingly
abandoned completely as a child overhaul
was abandoned himself and was taken in
by the boss of a criminal organization
now this boss raised him like a son and
consequently overhaul felt like he owed
the boss a huge debt and in turn he
wanted to repay that debt by bringing
the organization back to the previous
dominance that it once had because of
almost presence many criminal
organizations in Japan felt like they
couldn't thrive in the way they used to
with the exception of one for all and
all for one I believe chisaki has the
best quirk of anyone in my here academia
the name of the quirk is overall and it
gives him the ability to disassemble and
reassemble anything he touches with his
bare hands once he's taken something
apart he has the option to either leave
it completely destroyed or restore it to
its original form or indeed he can shape
it into something new or fuse it with
something else this is so overpowered
like he can essentially bend matter to
his will now in regards to his
personality overhaul is an extreme
sociopath like super extreme he
literally doesn't care for a single
person and will easily sacrifice those
close to him and even those who are
completely innocent and helpless such as
children as long as it helps him get
towards his goal of eradicating quirks
in society which he views as a sickness
and his other goal of getting the Yakuza
or specifically his organization back to
the top of the criminal pyramid as long
as it helps to achieve one or both of
those two things he will literally hurt
anyone
it doesn't matter quite strangely though
he is incredibly germaphobic and hates
anything he feels his dirty
he likes to avoid dirty places and if
people are dirty around him he's very
very uncomfortable sometimes overhaul
actually has a physical reaction if
there is too much dirt around him which
is weird for a guy who can literally
shape and bend mats to his will like he
could essentially touch anything he
thinks is dirty and make it clean so I
don't know it's a bit weird now
regarding relationships the only
and I can say that overall genuinely
cares for is the boss and even the boss
because of their disagreements overall
did some terrible things there are other
members of his group such as chrono
stasis who he actually values more than
just extras I guess but overall most
people probably could be used as a human
shield by the guy like he is pretty
merciless in that respect and that was
overall in two minutes if you like this
video then I recommend you subscribe to
the channel as you'd probably like the
content that I've already put out
additionally I have more videos like
this planned including next week where
I'm doing an explanation of sir night
eyes quirk because it is quite an
interesting one and as far as qwertz go
it's probably one of the least
straightforward quirks there are so
subscribe and stick around for that and
many other videos on the way and thank
you to everyone who retweeted my video
last week including obviously I have to
just say this again because it was so
crazy
including Rico Fajardo and see you next
week peace
you